[Music]
the idea came from my father
[Music]
he told me about their pictures on the
walls
and the subway stations of old buildings
you know old new york
20 years later after going through
everything school college and all that
stuff i thought i would finally give it
a look and to see what my father was
talking about
it was going to be a short article
i was going to illustrate some stations
with some pictures and tell the stories
but it
kind of ran away with me
what i've set out to do is make a record
of the appearance of the subway stations
in new york city
i take drawings of the mosaic or france
designs on the walls which embellish the
stations
i devote as much of my time as i can to
doing it
uh evenings or weekends vacation time
even
you know it's all sort of a consuming um
project
so far
i've completed four volumes on one two
three and four
my ambition is to take care of all the
lines until
all 490s
569
470 stations have been
recorded and seen
[Music]
why am i doing it
[Music]
okay
my purpose in doing this study is to
make a record of what we've got
i want to like document when it was done
and who did it
[Music]
so that's what i want to do that's my
focus is to give credit to those who
made it possible
i really started in earnest in 1978
and i thought i'd get this project
finished and wrapped up by the year 2030
which is only 14 years from now
perhaps i have to re-estimate and
suggest maybe
close to 2040.
i'll be
in my 90s then
hope i can still see
[Music]
the pleasure of doing the job is
his payment
i've committed to it that's all it's my
pur it's my purpose it's my life
it's become
my identity
so i have to live up to it
[Music]
i'm stephen wilsher i do drawings
steven is an artist who creates
incredibly intricate drawings of
cityscapes i love drawing tall buildings
tall skyscrapers skylines street scenes
and he does this entirely from memory
when stephen was three he was diagnosed
as autistic
he was completely mute and lived
entirely in his own world
early on steven's teachers noticed he
loved to draw
he had found his way to connect with
others
stephen has the ability to look at a
subject once and then draw an accurate
and detailed picture of it including
panoramas of entire cities based off
just a quick look i go up on a
helicopter and then memorize it and then
after being on a helicopter and then
straight back at the hotel and then
started to draw his incredible talent
launched an artistic career that has
taken him around the world
los angeles dubai houston texas
and
tokyo and japan and that's just to name
a few new york's my favorite empire
state building
chrysler building and there are lots of
yellow
new york taxi cabs and steven has no
plans of stopping anytime soon someone
told me that
people like me drawings joins
feel good always be happy about it
[Music]
these paintings they aren't done with
acrylic oil or watercolor
[Music]
microsoft excel the computer program
this is a story about tatsuo the
microsoft excel artist
[Music]
when tatsuwa retired he decided he
wanted to paint but there was one
problem
he was cheap
in the movies
he didn't even want to pay for an art
program so he used what was already on
his computer
so how do you paint in excel the line
tool it's usually used for spreadsheet
graphs that you can make trees with and
the bucket tool it helps with subtle
shading on for example the crest of a
volcano this week
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
people make assumptions all the time
so let's get the record straight
if i was a drug addict how could i have
possibly done all this
i'm lisa frank and
this madness that you see and all this
excitement started with me
[Music]
i know that you weren't comfortable
being on camera is there an element to
the secrecy
well the secrecy has worked for so long
like will i come out of the closet
i don't want to disappoint anybody what
if i'm not who they want me to be
our look has really been consistent for
30 years
and people have tried to tell me bright
colors aren't in you should do pastels
and it's not who i am
[Music]
we are entering the vault that has all
the original artwork in it
okay i better figure out how to open it
before you film it
the room is fireproof so that we don't
lose the original art
but look how bright everything still is
we were involved in the big sticker
craze in the 80s then it went to school
supplies because a sticker is an inch to
3 inches so it was more fun to get the
art bigger
and you can see it says library sample
do not remove that means like it's
probably
one of a kind
in hindsight we could have been even
smarter like keeping 12 of everything
there are some things i don't even have
[Music]
it was so exciting because we were onto
something that no one else was really
onto i mean people thought i had horns
coming out of my head when i would
suggest things early on
[Music]
the building's more than 300 000 square
feet and at one time like every bay was
filled up with trucks that was shipping
product out of here
in the beginning we probably had 30
artists at one time
unfortunately now we don't need as many
people in the art department because
things are much easier on the computer
so you now are doing only licensing
right now what we do is we do the
artwork for a whole bunch of other
companies who are then making it and
shipping
it i don't think i ever want to be a
manufacturer again
that takes away from who i am and what i
really love to do is to do artwork
[Music]
we want to
round out his face a little bit so he
looks a little
cuter
i've obviously learned a ton
over the years but in terms of the
artwork and the process i would say that
hasn't changed at all
it was never about making money it was
about making good product
and
having fun
[Music]
you